yeah welcome to this video and I'm
playing against Nikolai no Ritson
whoever that is but he's very high rated
25 something in the five minutes before
I play five and let's see what line we
get squat and let's see maybe he's
playing this line that from Nick
recently unearthed with age 38 3 is the
line yeah this is getting into fashion
interestingly enough read so it's not
really am something that looks very
threatening but it seems to be M
slightly annoying for black what what a
[ __ ] fascinating about this this line
is that white is really am easily am
allowing the exchange of the dark
squared bishop sigh always thought that
this exchange would actually help black
and in some way of course you need to be
cautious about the dark square some in
relation to the pawn on d5 nc6 so so
blockading ideas but still I always
believe that increasing the stability of
the knight on f6 would would help like
but um somehow this attracts a wide
players it was even though features in
the last round game in nerve of Tata
Steel between them one how and
world champion vishy anand and yeah one
how use this line to to defeat them are
not so on it's it needs to be taken
seriously it seems ok this um yeah also
a text the people on but I wanted to I
wanted to make sure that c4 isn't so
easily playable so um there isn't a
tactical on under on the roof rookie
seven would introduce the Bishop g4
tactic unfortunately I cannot turn I
cannot play Quincy three Bishop h7
coming I wonder if you can take here of
course you can but if it if it is
beneficial okay I try a 5a for getting
rid of one porn weakness it somehow
feels that that black shouldn't be a
really in bad shape but it also it's
rather comfortable for white to play
he's got them good positions for his
pieces and it's very hard to believe
that white could get in any serious
trouble soon I mean how how would you
manage to lose such a position rather
difficult
and now a too is Sam at least something
that I can attack but we can probably
cover with rookie to which also prepares
exactly prepares to to double to double
the rocks so Bishop to d7 i can even
exchange more stuff probably it it is
not bad to do that yeah just rupee 8
getting rid of more pieces I'm not sure
it looks very young and ambitious this
way of playing for black but Brooke on a
eight is the worst piece than the Lucani
too so exchanging it's probably the way
to go and I know it mean he is not so
easily i'm getting at my pawns well
under some circumstances a 2 and C 3 can
can really be a slight weakness okay
grab here and queen d6 back oh wait wait
wait just a min just a second what about
g5g five he's got down 9h five I can I
can pin this night and g3 is not really
a move that helps wide so aged six let's
just improve the slightly maybe I can
play g5 gaining some getting some useful
space
yeah I don't mind no don't mind to play
c5 ready putting a poll on the dark
square here yeah that's really not much
going on Queen e6 what you detect age
three and maybe initiate the Queen trade
not sure that I want that okay maybe
just improve the King a bit and maybe
Queenie seven coming really f3 what does
this move doing really not sure what
this move is accomplishing I go here he
just wants to retreat or whatever I
completely forgot about the square okay
I just forgot that he can go to f4 this
is a bit annoying that he's got this
possibility at all okay didn't didn't
really use it in any way
yeah the time is so the problem the
position is sir more than okay now
tweenage to teachers done lost the
thread here 25 does queenie one coming
let's keep it simple okay I don't don't
see a winner no no no no that's not so
easy
you really need to find moves first that
don't lose instantly okay maybe I should
have taken the draw but it just felt
very stupid like after he blundered to
this to totally lost position to accept
a draw I'm just playing bet I mean this
is just a win very easy Tommy yeah well
and every move wins of course but it's
just a matter of doing it there in time
24-22 yeah there was simply not much
happening in this game and here I
actually blundered to this and now he
blundered back with Lucy form which is
just ridiculous c4 just just giving away
the spawn end of the complete position
to a loss but I I spent too much time
24s miss made already and so on I mean
it's also a bit of a problem of this non
increment I'm control now yeah it was
still interesting I mean this is so long
line doesn't really I think you promised
wide too much there was simply not much
happening in this whole game until I we
both blundered enter then I basically
lost it due to time yeah thanks for
watching